trompa trinado 550 veces desde el 3 de
noviembre de las elecciones y un tercio
de estos trinos han sido para criticar
el sistema electoral para no reconocer
la derrota electoral del 3 de noviembre
y lo que analistas dicen es que
públicamente tiene un discurso de
precisamente no reconocer esta derrota
pero en los tribunales porque no
presenta pruebas porque su equipo legal
no tiene los argumentos necesarios para
respaldar el fraude pues siempre sigue y
sigue perdiendo en los tribunales así
que donald trump se está acercando y se
está tratando de brindar su mensaje
político blindarse políticamente con el
apoyo de sus simpatizantes que fueron
más de 70 millones de personas que
votaron por él a pesar de que en los
tribunales sigue perdiendo además pues a
esto hay que sumarle también angela que
los republicanos ya le están diciendo el
presidente trump que ya es hora de que
acepte la derrota y que empiece la
transición para bien de eeuu
cristóbal y en el otro lado de la
barrera joe biden se va a la segura con
nominados que ya trabajaron a su lado en
los gobiernos de barack obama su equipo
está promoviendo estos dos nombramientos
como una muestra de diversidad es así y
john kerry será clave en un cambio de
enfoque frente a la emergencia climática
si de hecho john kerry durante este
tiempo después de haber salido del
gobierno de barack obama montó una ong
para el cuidado del cambio climático ha
hecho acercamientos incluso con los
progresistas era la progresista del
partido demócrata con alexandro caso
corte es precisamente para avanzar esta
agenda verde este iniciativa de crear
empleos verdes infraestructura verde que
tiene el gobierno de giovanni en los
próximos cuatro años pero
definitivamente la diversidad es pues el
factor que une a todos los que han sido
mencionados y nombrados por el
presidente electo joe biden que hoy
desde delaware confirmaría esos nombres
cuatro características además de la
diversidad primero que son de fácil
aceptación en el senado teniendo en
cuenta que lo más probable es que un
senador republicano siga en en la cámara
alta también pues que son veteranos de
obama pero a este tema de la diversidad
hay que sumarle también el tema de la
experiencia son personas que tienen pues
más de 20 años de experiencia el caso de
janet yellen
una economista laborista muy conocida
con mucho recorrido también el caso de
ebro james y de tomás winfield así que
además del caso de la diversidad y de
que pueda ser un tema de cuota pues esta
diversidad se respalda con experiencia y
pues es entonces esas características
comunes que comparten estos nominados
por yo vaya gracias cristóbal y feliz
día